I'm in full capability to bring home a
gold medal one of the best hurlers ever
to come through the NCAA to be our icon
it's just someone that you know sets the
example at an early age you know I
started working out starting figuring
out my body starting figure out what I
like from there work done and worked on
and worked on to perfect my craft kind
of develop into this this beast that I
am now feel a little bit more pressure
on myself tonight and they're not sure
it but I mean we're all human we all
care about what we do and there's
someone out there working their butt off
right now I don't really follow a
routine you know pretty more worried
less figuring out you know how to get
better each day day in and day out the
faster you figure out the faster you
work towards that goal I see myself
running till I'm 45 tips you know as
long as I can't run you know as long as
my body allows me to run I love that
adrenaline that comes before race when
we step foot on that line for those 12
seconds I don't know him it's okay to be
different it's okay to do you know other
things that may not be the norm
what no I'm can operate today